We often think of complaining as negative, but it can lead to improvements when done effectively.
Being hostile, self-pitying and offering no solutions are the wrong way.
A balanced approach is to be reasonable, realistic and respectful.
In fact, effective complaining entails knowledge, attitude and skills.
Knowledge is power.
Know the facts and your rights, know where to complain and know what you want and who can support you.
Attitude is everything.
Frustration, resentment and sadness will work against you.
Be flexible, empathetic, rational, nonjudgmental and solution oriented.
You will need communication, organizational and negotiating skills.
You will need to be able to ask questions, summarize and present problems clearly and be a good listener.
You need to keep detailed records and evidence.
Lastly, you need to be able to discern what is important,...
...put yourself into the other person's shoes...
...and be clear about compromises you are willing to make.